Republican Congressman George Anthony
devolder Santos says he would rather go
to jail than name the people who
guaranteed his 500 000 Bond when he was
booked well that's a possibility and
indeed George Santos could could end up
in jail if he doesn't reveal them as a
judge has ordered him to do now we
talked about this on the award-winning
bonus Show recently oh the bonus show
where you want to make money yeah
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad right as Alex Jones
says there we made money on the bonus
show talking about the story on the one
hand I agree that if you are simply a
private person and you know George
Santos and you were willing to guarantee
his bond
it's not necessarily a nice thing to
have your name all over the news
at the same time there shouldn't be any
special protections for George Santos
because of who he is